I think I'll get started that's right so
good morning everyone and welcome today
to our weekend I'm going to be talking
about read alignment today and read
mapping and before I started just wanted
to say that when we were organizing the
workshop and i should say we I mean
literally run shamir because he didn't
just do most of the work you did all of
the work we're discussing what kind of
topics to do and how boot camps work and
that the goal of a boot camp is kind of
not to give a research talk but together
an introduction that's suitable for
students and postdocs and also those who
are just from outside the field and so I
tried to prepare the the talk with that
in mind and and the sort of sort of
shortly after we started to to think
about this so I started trying to think
about you know where to begin in the
beginning because I wanted to give us a
bit of a historical overview and so the
thing is I realized that I have a bit of
a challenge because my topic doesn't
exist so I went to this thing called the
Google Ngram viewer which has lined the
corpus of all books in English and other
languages and there you can type words
like sequence alignment to read
alignment and it shows usually two plots
this is the usage of the word sequence
alignment in books and you can see that
the subject is kind of you know it's a
little bit hard to see because of the
scale but that's 1970 and then sort of
taking off in the 80s and 90s but read
alignment sort of just blanked there was
not a single example of the term read
alignment in the entire corpus of the
English language so now I tried to move
this up to tutta you cannot disks to the
ends of 2008 so I thought okay maybe
it's not all right
yes just really this covers books yeah
you're right so then I went to where I
gather all my information when I prepare
talks and I went to Wikipedia and
there's no Wikipedia page for read along
if you can believe that and then I knew
I was in great trouble because there
goes my secret you know trick for
preparing all my like sort of
introductory talks so this yeah there's
a page about this program called boat
I'll say what about later there's list
of software your head already about
about the burrows-wheeler transform
which is used in read alignment but
there's no actual that Henry is of
course mr. Reed alignment but there is
no kind of page about ritalin so I knew
I was in trouble so I thought okay
journals conferences somewhere okay so i
went first of all I should say actually
that there is a page for sequence
alignment but it's very long but it has
one line about reader language so that
was in useful so i went to i searched
recom yeah this is a main conference i
first went to recommend i think in the
very first recon in santa fe many years
ago so you can search the recon on
google scholar actually a couple of
hundred papers of appeared in recon and
that constitutes in line kind of the
corpus of computer science for biology
yearly annual conference that's
important in our field and there are
exactly three papers in the entire recon
that have ever mentioned the word
readalong the fridge villain and so
these two are so these two over here
actually have read alignment in a
citation so this is from the citations
lee and urban road one of the first
papers on the birds will transform and
then there's one single paper which is
actually not quite about realignment
it's about it's from surfing box opens
group it was just in the last year
coming 2015 it's about something called
molecular technology I'll say maybe
something about it it's a new technology
for kind of building long fragments of
DNA from short reads it's completely
obsolete actually already and so in fact
this paper and its companion Genome
Research have no citations and we'll see
how that goes because the technology no
longer really exists in a way it's kind
of being completely obsolete already in
a year and that's actually an
interesting point because you know one
of the issues with this particular
lecture and this whole subject is that
it's very technology-focused frequently
and so so there you go so there's no
recon and so I I tried to go back to the
actual Simon's Institute website to
figure maybe I got the wrong talk you
know okay there's no topic that I'm
supposed to talk about but it said
mapping in alignment and so I went back
inside Reed napping because I may be a
read alignments not there well there's
there's no read mapping either in entire
recall has never been mentioned a single
time you might say maybe recall actually
is a conference that has a kind of a
really great actually companion meeting
that I went to in 2015 in Poland based
44 kind of sequencing specifically but
that meaning is fairly new and you would
think that there would be something in
recon so aside from the paper by
Seraphim buzzer goes on the steering
committee of the conference on there's
nothing so that's the state of alignment
it's a topic nobody cares about so I'll
try to do my best though to convince you
that it's sort of interesting maybe and
maybe I'll answer the question why I
think it's never been in any of these
conferences books so I thought about
this for a while they realized maybe I
should talk actually that sequence
aligned now it's a bit awkward because
there's been an entire day and and Dan
gosfield just gave an extraordinary
they're all on video by the way to go
back at you know like an entire day of
lectures with Mike Waterman and they
literally wrote
book so to speak but I realized that you
know if you go look at a at sequence
alignment there's lots and lots of
papers and I realized that to really
talk about really a read alignment I
maybe should talk about sequence
alignment and try to explain the
difference because unfortunately the
thing is that when it comes to sequence
alignment it's frequently presented and
written about is a kind of string
matching kind of endeavor but in fact
and read alignment sequence alignment
whatever those things are they're both
about matching strings but in sort of
very different ways and I think it's
important understand the context in the
biology and the difference to really
understand why they're not really the
same subject there anyway so what I'm
going to do in the tutorial today is
basically go to a couple of definitions
and try to tell you what I actually
think biological sequence alignment is
because that wasn't on your city so that
would be something you and I'll talk a
little bit about what read alignment is
were kidnapping and then kind of compare
and contrast and then I'll tell you a
bit about algorithms for these things
I'll tell you I heard about the bars
real chance for I'll say a word about
that I'm not going to go too much in
depth into the algorithms I want to talk
a little bit about blast for a number of
reasons I'll talk about a new concept I
tried to keep research material out of
this tutorial but there is one thing I
do want to discuss you the language it
also relates to assembly which is one of
the topics for this week so so that's
kind of the outline and I'll try to
sprinkle in a few questions that are
ridic for people to think about for the
for the remaining semester so let me
start with sequence alignment and
explain what I think it really is just
my personal opinion but I think it's
important as i said to understand and so
for me sequence alignment actually
begins with this famous a picture of
darwin's notebook where he drew the
first a phylogenetic tree and actually
not the first tree and Lamarck
beforehand drew lots of trees but they
were just a slightly different than
LaMarcus trees had the interior nodes
labeled and Darwin only labeled the
leaves that's really the difference
between them and and so really this
[ __ ] is famous it's shown frequently in
talks what I like to say about this
picture is that it's actually a
mathematical statement and Darwin and
never did any math but he appreciated
math on he was terrified of it but I
actually credit him for a math idea and
I'd like to tell you what it is related
to sequence alignment underlying
Darwin's picture is actually and you've
seen many trees like this all of you I'm
sure even those of you from outside of
computational biology underlying this
picture is this notion computer science
of what's called a hierarchy and
hierarchy is on a collection of sets if
you like so this notation to the X
there's a set X in this case ABCD and 2
to the power of X are all the subsets of
X and in a hierarchy you have a
collection of subsets of a set so you
want to eat you our subsets of X and
they satisfy a condition that any pair
of them are either disjoined or one is
contained inside the other and so just
in this example of Darwin's tree the set
X has a BCD which label the leaves here
I should say that in this picture of
Darwin you know other than you can read
I think it's a little bit hard to read
that part and he certainly did think you
have these little feet those are the
extant species in the tree and then the
the branches that are single lecture no
don't have feet are extinct species
species went extinct on but he labeled
ABCD they're kind of extant species and
one is the root of the tree that's kind
of the common ancestor and in this
picture in the set X you have a
hierarchy which consists of the
following sets a
CD and then the set b c d and then the
set ABCD and this hierarchy if you think
about it for a second you'll realize
that these are the leaves the PCD is the
ancestor of these three extant species
and then ABCD is the ancestor of all of
the taxes so in fact a hierarchy
represents a set of extant species and
their common ancestors and it's a
theorem that's actually not not hard but
it's a little exercise for the afternoon
to prove that every semi labeled tree
like this that is to say tree with his
file whose leaves are labeled root a
tree like this corresponds to a set
system like this in every set system to
one of these pictures so they are in by
jection with each other and this fact is
actually you know it's kind of an
important fact because it has many names
so I said this was a computer science
idea and in fact it's not hierarchies
the combinatorics the math people
kawasaki the computer scientists call
this a laminar family and it's used a
lot in proving things about our greedy
algorithms this kind of rejection space
the concept in computer science you know
in Dan's book I think Dan Gospels Book I
think it's called a perfect fine lodging
maybe let's say so it's got many names
because in mathematics you know sitting
good ideas keep cropping up people
different people figure them out so so
yeah so I've written I've written up a
couple of the the names here so so
Darwin kind of had this idea not in the
context of math although let's give him
the credit for that I think he deserves
it he added in the context of biology he
really imagined that these leaves are
you know birds like finches or some
other kind of species that's what he had
in mind but what's really different
starting in the mid 60's around the
early to mid 60's is that biologists
started to think about this structure
but with first protein sequences
and later DNA sequences labeling the
leaves of this tree that's kind of was a
fundamental conceptual change in biology
because it's a different idea to think
of the actual objects that are evolving
being actual nucleotides or amino acids
or polymers of some kind than actual
entire species right that's kind of a
very different thing and I've tried to
do homework on this and I believe
actually that the very first example of
doing a kind of actual sequence analysis
or alignment goes back to Linus Pauling
in the zucher candle and around 1963 at
Caltech they kind of started by
sequencing globins different globins and
actually doing alignments of them in
this string sense that you heard about
yesterday so taking the strings and
trying to fit them together and compare
them but what they were really doing is
actually trying to sort of fit together
the evolutionary history of these
sequences and I'm going to try to
belabor this point actually so what they
were really doing was and later when
they saw one day and other switch to
using DNA's when they are kind of trying
to match these strings up there trying
to actually say look this nucleotide and
not a nucleotide in this one they have a
common ancestry in the sense of this
hierarchy of Darwin so that's what they
mean and so in fact my view of what a
sequence alignment is I call it a
homology forest because in biology the
sewer homology means that different
characters let's say nucleotides DNA
sequences have a common ancestry and
what you should really think of is a big
forest like this and it's very horrible
conceptual picture but you have lots of
love trees that might be different there
might be the same and each one of them
each one of its tips is labeled with a
sequence character of one of the genomes
let's say that you're looking at and
they're all related to each other and
all of these trees they may be slightly
different
they're four nucleotides that may have a
different history they're all related to
each other because there's a species
evolution on top of them so it's kind of
a more complicated way to think of
things but I truly think of the
alignments like this so for example when
you see genomes being aligned what
really you should actually think of in
your mind it's not the strings and their
comparison but you should actually think
of the individual nucleotides which I've
here just picked some from different
chromosomes so this is a literally
selling nucleotide in the genome you
should think about it being related to
possibly other nucleotides in the same
genome because some nucleotides in the
same genome have a shared common
ancestry by duplication but some
nucleotides you know have ancestry with
other species and of course it's very
very complicated and it's actually a
true force and not a tree because there
are copying errors during replication
and nucleotides just pop up and
nucleotides get deleted so not every
nucleotide shares a common ancestry with
every other nuclear time that might be
true for all the species on earth but
not for their genomes so when we're
doing a sequence alignment we're
actually building a vast number of trees
like this now people try to fixate on
this goes with that and this and that
but actually part and parcel of the
whole problem is to figure out the tree
that relates them as well and that's
very difficult but often necessary to
get the correspondences right so that's
what sequence alignment is all about
it's a horribly difficult problem yeah
so your people as I said they fixate on
these ovals but their real question is
very difficult and actually I don't know
if you remember the very first slide
with the Google n-grams and went up and
up and up but then it sort of was wobbly
on top and that's basically because this
is so hard that not actually many people
are working on it so I don't actually
know of many groups that are trying to
really do the research and to whole
genome alignment right now it's
difficult problem yep so what about the
chicken at the bottom right
oh that's what's my point that this
particular nucleotide right it might be
a completely new insertion in the
chicken so it's just a tool and you want
to identify those as well so actually
there's even more complexity here
because really you are too kind of in an
ideal world you'd be able to label each
one of these nodes with a date or a
generation right that's really hard it's
probably not a problem you can actually
solve but it's an interesting question
how far you can get and you know that's
so that's why I put this here exactly I
should have said that thank you so how
does this truly relate to kind of the
pictures that we're more used to in
biological sequence alignment well you
know we have on often sequences like
this kind of align on top of each other
with these dashes for gaps I'm
suggesting that you really ought to
imagine that decorated on top of this
picture or decorating a picture are
these trees and they might be different
and you'd like to know them all right
and the point is that i should say when
you look at this picture it's not just
that there are trees decorating each
column the columns actually have an
order because the sequences have an
order and so there's actually a
relationship between the trees and
there's actually you know quite a lot of
difficult different complicated things
that can happen from this evolutionary
point of view this is a valid sequence
alignment where these set your three
sequences share some history of these
chess tree and the two sets don't share
in history at all so actually the order
in which I put these two sets doesn't
matter right I could have flipped them
around but within each of them you order
matters because they're real sequences
so to my knowledge it pretty much with
one or two exceptions there are no
software programs for example in biology
that can even output this actual kind of
picture because when you just think of
comparing strings directly actually this
kind of solution almost always has kind
of score of minus infinity or
probability zero because you can always
kind of maybe shift over something a
little bit you know there's an N right
there and that matches up maybe you just
shove those together
yeah but maybe it's not the right
evolutionary answer so I wanted to
actually say that this issue this is not
what my talk is about to this is just an
aside it's quite important actually
there's database called scope and
there's actually some other database as
well these are databases that create
protein sequences and structures and
actually one of the pioneers in doing
this is Steven Brenner who's here at
Berkeley and here in the room and going
to be around the workshop so a good
person to talk to in this kind of
database these kind of alignments
actually are important because often
proteins have domains that don't relate
to each other or there are just
representatives in the database that are
actually unrelated also you'd like to
completely yank them apart so there's a
kind of actual structure to this and
I'll stop with the sequence alignment in
a minute because it's really a tutorial
about read alignment but the actual
structure for thinking about sets of
forests of trees is a concept called the
file genetic orange and American talked
about it today but the laws of
interested I have notes from the course
I talking at Berkeley once about this
object and its it comes up in
phylogenetics but it's actually a
sequence alignment object and I think
would be very interesting to think about
about those sort of things there's also
an actual more computer science
structure for thinking about alignments
that relates the evolutionary homology
forced perspective i just gave to the
standard string ecology perspective and
that's the notion of a dad or partially
ordered set on the columns of an
alignment so in in this representation a
standard alignment is actually a
directed acyclic graph with numbers on
the nodes so that as you go from bottom
to top you always increase the number
this is called the topological ordering
and there have been a couple of folks
who've written papers about this kind of
structure for alignments and and worked
with that again each one of these notes
has a tree
writing it but you know in this kind of
setting you can kind of shuffle order
around when notes are not ordered by
this partially ordered set or the stag
so this is all nice but it has proc do
theoretically it's fun to think about
file genetic oranges but it actually is
practical significance and and that will
bring you to read alignment because I'm
going to make a key point for the
tutorial so when people just compare
strings they run into trouble with
actual biological sequences and there's
a very nice paper making exactly this
point it's by sheraton windsor a couple
of years ago back when it's right at the
this is right the year when the last
year for sequence alignment before all
those folks switched over to read
alignment who are very nice paper kind
of pointing out that there's this kind
of four issues with sequence alignments
and give them names GaPO under gaap
attraction gap annihilation two
different types of gap attraction and I
see what you're saying is you know
there's just cases that happen in
practice where you have for example this
setting where gcg it could actually you
know wonder between these two sides
because maybe it fits pretty well to
both A's and G's transition or basically
have a higher probability than a species
and then they sort of gap attraction if
you have a sequence and then in a little
an exact match alignment programs will
kind of tend to glue these together
because it becomes difficult to model
all the kind of I think then guess who
actually said this year on its heart you
you run out of scores and scoring
schemes eventually and so you get these
kind of issues and you know I like this
one you know this might be the true
revolutionary story but it's sometimes
just easier to just shove everything
together and it gives you a slightly
higher score but whatever metric epic
and it's not a theorem but it's a truth
that no matter what you try to do with
standard alignment schemes you for every
line that's going to exist some a corner
case that will
that one should name that looks like
this okay and the resolution to this is
not to try to go about making fancier
and fancier and fancier scoring seems
reliance but to think about things
statistically and I was really helped
you in dan goes field yesterday actually
said those exact words what you really
kind of like to do is take a picture
like this and make it into a picture
like this where these colors so now
intuitively tell you that you're not so
reliable about going together these
things are those things and I'm going to
try not to talk about network but we
wrote a program former student line of
an option postdoc of mine a student in
homes in collaboration with in here at
Berkeley rewrote it a program called FSA
which implemented algorithms that I
won't discuss today there are based on
this kind of partially ordered set view
of alignments and produce this kind of
statistical information and I actually
think that that's kind of the key
because in the absence of this
uncertainty information you can't make
sense of alignments so that's what
really biological sequence alignment is
all about sequence alignment is
sequences that have a shared
evolutionary history where you'd like to
understand that history and understand
your uncertainty in declaring it because
if you think about the big forest for
all three billion nucleotides in human
genome and all species 50,000
vertebrates or mammals I think actually
um you know you you're going to not be
able to resolve for every nucleotide
where it goes and we lose its what's
part you're going to have to do this the
distance so that's what sequence
alignment is yes I've been struggling to
space whether i should say something or
not you don't even explain where is that
it's six come from i haven't explained
it because that's not what my tutorial
is about yeah but when you have a pair
how are you how are you going to come up
with all these evolution stories if you
want to relate so you if you would like
to take a pair and come up with a
meaningful statistical estimate of the
reliability of alignment you need to
have lots and lots of sequences during
string sequence alignment on a single
pair of sequences is
innocence hortons because your model is
going to be fairly simplistic and not
have enough data so that is absolutely
true and this is kind of you know this
is kind of a screenshot from a bigger
picture just still like make this
comparison but you can't figure these
settings out without a lot more
information and sometimes you just can't
figure that at all right so so my point
is very simple but anything that you can
have statistical information about you
will be able to come up with an
algorithm to model it and you don't need
any statistics once once you have a
model so it's what's not about whether
you need or don't need statistics the
point is the output is a probability
because it doesn't make sense to declare
whether a you know I that is my point
you see it's not that I'm saying that
you need a statistical method to do the
alignment although I happen to think we
do that we could argue about it but my
point here was different that your
output is a statistical information a
probability because you cannot otherwise
it just doesn't make sense but you
cannot say this was here that goes there
that's kind of my keeping some people
for example in RNA already do that in a
way there's a lot of work in that
direction right do we have a partition
functions so actually it's a very good
point so in RNA sequence alignment
there's exactly kind of very statistical
physics point of view because the
original folks with this conferences and
it's true although it's also true that
very few folks even in the RNA world
actually output even for their programs
just practically speaking the actual
ensemble they also tend to fixate on
okay this is kind of and an RNA
structure ball just really bothers them
because there is no such thing as a
single fold for 4 from molecules in
people yeah so far up to 23 notes
for more detailed version of this and
what's in plunger you have to look at
the impulses he talks about it
extensively ourselves for various
purpose coming back to historical that
you mentioned that calling with a
personal the first alignments that's
partly true but in fact Kendra fruit
Scotland well prize in 1962 for their
discovery of the structures of myoglobin
and hemoglobin and there are two
important things they discovered when
they solve the structures moments that
rather being beautiful they expected
they were these are rioting disgusting
horrible things the second thing with a
look at the structures of myoglobin and
hemoglobin which were known to be able
to relate to each other there we'll see
if they could align them together
structurally which we can protea lineman
it was a structural alignment then later
on actually out after and they got the
Nobel Prize then were able to get the
sequences the structures came long
before the sequence exactly when the
alignment sequences they could not have
told that those two proteins are related
from the sequences even though it was
immediately obvious from the structures
and I'm happy you said that because as
you can see biological sequence
alignment when discussed with biologists
it's very complicated and it's
absolutely true that you often want to
do structural and that's a whole other
story absolutely absolutely very true
yes when it comes to sequence the line
tight i encourage you to have a look at
the fact that paper that i was involved
with was primarily pasamos by how much
it says to find the partition function
of two interacting rnase it's pretty
much sequence alignment yep it tells you
at a single reason why you're not doing
it is it's order n to the power 6 that's
right oh so that's completely my and I
don't share preference but that's what I
believe what you do is calculate
partition functions the point of this
project and I'm not discussing it is how
to calculate how to estimate these kind
of probabilities without actually
calculating a whole partition function
so then we should have a chart because
this we actually also applied can apply
to RNA and there's many things to
discuss and that's why i'm so happy that
we finally have a computational biology
program at the silence
so very last point I'll make about
sequence alignment there was actually a
paper earlier this year well last year
showing a very nice result that edit
distance is hard and this is what we all
work on so the exact result by buckers
in in dec from MIT was that that edit
distance cannot be computed in strongly
sub quadratic time meaning that if you
could do that then what's called this
strongly exponential time apophysis Seth
would have to be true and would actually
be kinda nice in this program to go
through that result because this is kind
of an interesting hypothesis that's
debated whether it's actually true or
not yeah so it's not entirely true clear
whether this is actually true or not
this has to do with looking at case at
and sequences for the exponent in case
out to very interesting story you know
when this was written people wrote about
it that said okay well it's basically
going to be impossible to line two human
genomes I don't think that's true
because that's as I just try to say
that's not what you do with sequence
alignment right so all right so yeah
will be great to like work through this
results of the semester I think that's
actually a good project so read
alignment now get to the actual tutorial
it's a different type of problem
altogether it came about when people
started generative reads from sequences
so I'm not going to deliver talk much
about it there's been sequences for a
while this is what they used to look
like and sequences produce sequences of
DNA but not very long sequences of DNA
usually I mean back in these days a
couple of hundred base pairs reads so
reads are just a short bit of sequence
that comes out a machine like this the
machine will produce lots and lots of
reeds I'll say more about what reads
look like today but this was a new
technology and it really came online in
the mid 90s people started to actually
get DNA sequences this machine sequence
DNA
by producing lots and lots of reads to
be short tish sequences and then have to
do something with them and the first
paper i could find that actually
mentioned the word read alignment was
program called Khan said and frappe by
full green and his collaborators in 1998
and they had this picture actually in
the paper and I believe this is the
first read alignment going on and hear
what's going on is that you have strings
but they're reads their DNA sequences
came on machine and many of them are the
same because the nature of the way you
use these machines is that you sequence
the same DNA sequence over and over and
over for reasons that have to do with
assembly and other things that I will
not talk about today and when you have
these reads what they did is they
actually are lined them to each other
and actually what they did is they were
technically speaking aligning the reeds
to context that were assembled from the
DNA so contig is a longer piece of
sequence obtained by gluing together
with DNA and then they took all the
reeds and they try to compare them to
the content and to each other and that
was the first sequence length and the
goal here was to find errors in the
sequence still today an important thing
to do so you know they're here they just
didn't have information for you know you
can see if you look carefully for
example here there's some other little
piece of sequence here but everybody
else says something else so maybe that
sequence was wrong so this is a
completely different thing in sequence
alignment because there's no tree
decorating these sequences they're not
related evolutionarily there's no
they're simply the same sequence with
error that's all that's going on and the
goal is to find the error nowadays
sometimes the goal is to take a
reference sequence that's previously
been assembled let's say from shank is
you know take my reads from my genome
and find out where they are different
because you see he believes in straight
up algorithms computer science and I
like statistics so we want to find out
where in the
DNA like what makes us different okay so
that so then you want to align the reach
to the genome but it's really got
nothing to do sequence alignment it's a
completely different question and so the
methods for doing this are very
different so I try to formalize a little
bit for this talk actually like what a
real line it is and I wrote a blog post
about it a little while ago if you want
to go read preparing for this very slide
this is kind of very crude and not
precise because it's difficult to do
this precisely but I'll just try to
recruit Li you can think of sort of what
a realignment it really is okay is it's
kind of a pair of maps where this
calligraphy off-script f is your set of
all fragments I prefer to call them
fragments then reads actually so you
would call the fragment alignment talk
today because sometimes these fragments
are connected to each other somehow with
other information so i think on the set
of fragments and you kind of want to
know for a collection of sequences I
kind of weird first of all these
fragments come from yeah which sequence
that they originated from you believe
that these fragments are literally
copies from some original sequences
there's a whole bunch of them and
they're in the settee which one is this
guy from and then when you when you
think about so the settee here are the
different contexts in fat but once you
pick the contact you actually want to
know this a right here goes without a
and not that a over there so you want to
actually have a detailed map for every
individual nucleotide here where it
actually goes over there and so that's
this map elsebeth for a specific
fragment it gives you a map between the
this notation that means the positions
in that fragment and the positions in
its specific target which is why you see
so why is it actually not a very precise
definition well if you would like to
write this precisely it becomes a kind
of you know experiment for mathematician
and optic because the fragments can
actually because these are d
I sequences that could be in reverse
complement and they could they could be
in pairs and it could be all sorts of
things and then this just becomes like a
whole lot of notation but that's the
basic concept I just intuitively wanted
to get across so that's the first thing
the second thing is an error model in
order to actually produce these maps you
need to know something about how there
are errors in your sequences when I told
you that's the only thing that isn't
sequences is error and actually I left
this up because I just got tired every
time I type frap phra p that's converted
a frappe so let's just call it frat ok
so the program frappe actually it gave a
score of 11 for a match a minus 2 for a
mismatch minus 4 for a gap in minus
three for extending a gap is actually
the logic inside frap I went to look it
up but your error model might be
different you might give a different
score you might do a probability if you
even ventured and try to do some
statistical thing the next thing is that
you need a kind of efficient data
structure for computing this maps I you
say basically when filaggrin did this
and it's kind of hard to put himself in
the mindset but in 1998 you'll you did
there were no there are no macbook airs
in fact my apple was about to go
bankrupt and there were no computers
constituted the sort of boxes that could
add a tiny bit of memory and couldn't do
much and so it's a hard to put yourself
in the mindset but it is very difficult
to take all these sequences and just
figure out which context they came from
how do you do that so so what they did
is they is the hash which means they
took exact sub sequences and try to find
out whether they exist in one of the
context so standard computer science
thing and that's how they did in fact
and then finally they actually needed to
align this map l sub f you know each
single individual base in the read and
in this frat paper they use the Bandit
smith-waterman algorithm so
basically on this is frappe and it's
actually this is what riddle I'm it is
big picture wise all the following
programs and software many years later
they're all kind of this is basically
what they do they make different choices
for this part different choices for that
part different choices for this but they
do that okay so so that's what they do
yeah I mean they weren't actually always
very long but you're assuming they were
longer than your reads right so yeah and
in frappe you assumed you had context so
like that skirt so a few years after
frappe people started generate a lot
more data and they actually kind of
couldn't handle it like they really
needed in fact in 2001 they accomplished
the human genome and then people wanted
to take the reeds and find out where in
the human genome do they align to now
it's not a contig anymore but a 2.8
billion base pairs Oh divided into
chunks but but a huge amount of sequence
and that's actually I finished my PhD 99
so I was just coming online right then
and people needed to do this so these
blasts and people actually still use
blast to do realignment sometimes
because they don't know that they
shouldn't okay but that it's really bad
idea but they still do that because it's
just been around for so long I just want
to say for a second what blast did what
blast actually did is your kind of did a
similar thing kind of first kind of his
hash to find exact matches and then kind
of try to extend those matches and
there's a nice Theory gun blast we're
now you don't do a slaughterman language
starting with your exact match you sort
of walk along and you actually have this
random walk when you have a match you
move up and when you have a mismatching
you're down and this example here
corresponds to that one and your
statistic etest is how high is it from
the troughs to the peaks that's why I
said necks and Sam Carlin
and ultra they proved some theorem that
gave some distribution for these chhath
to peak Heights on which you could build
a test to actually pull out significant
matches so that's what they did this
program was designed for sequence
alignment well lets you take one protein
sequence you want to compare to another
in a database or one DNA sequence
compared to another in a database so
it's actually complete again it's our
apples and oranges you don't really want
to do this but I don't want to tell
people in this program that if they'd
like an exercise for warm-up it's
actually the study blast because nobody
has actually ever looked except to my
knowledge a student took a class at to
get a final project on this actually
calculated the exact statistics which
you can now do there's now computers are
pretty good and with the weather sexual
approximation is any good and it turns
out it's not very good so that's another
interesting thing today yeah it's okay
and I can tell you why because the thing
is this approximation is good when n the
size of the sequence is small as the
sequence gets longer and longer
approximation deteriorates and since
proteins are freely bounded in length
that's why it's probably pretty good for
proteins so interesting to study for the
theoretical purpose maybe not so
practically although there's still a lot
of databases where people do need to
blast honest you know sequences that are
evolutionary related so it would be an
inch another interesting little project
for for the semester yes this pattern
along the Texas it's a different
statistical problem that in one blast
goes for I agree yeah that's that's my
point really that was why I mentioned I
thought I tell people what not to do as
well so or what people shouldn't so
there been a lot of improvements in
technology an unfortunate thing about
realignment and the hard part about
working on it is you have to be very
technology savvy as I said molecular for
example I was a big group about two
years ago takes a while to write a paper
and a method is now kind of obsolete and
this is how fast the technology is
moving and it started really moving
around two thousand three this is from
the PhD thesis of a twofer of murder
former student of mine he made this plot
the size of the circles the radius is
the read length and log scale of that
technology and the thickness of the
boundary is the error rate of the
technology and this is the year and this
is the cost and you know it's going
there starting 2003 about a hundred
million dollars to sequence the DNA
necessary to get a genome now a thousand
and you can just see that this is log
scale this is an extraordinary rapid
increase in speed of genuine reads you
can also see why Google Scholar didn't
find anything in books because this if
you kind of look at it I mean aside from
this one bubble here there's kind of
really a phase transition here or
suddenly there's a lot of stuff so able
just didn't work on it but it was the
problem to work on and now these
machines of which there are many and all
of your institutions generate a huge
amount of reads every day Tara basis per
run and I don't like to like emphasize
how much data there is because there's
just this plenty so this is leave it
apart and all these Reed's need to be
aligned why do they need to be aligned
so let me say a word about that so oh
actually well yeah let me skip to why in
a second
on how are they went I was going to pour
into this to tell you what people did
during 2008 so in 2008 people started
writing papers and there were a couple
of programs that were published both
have bwn ackles two programs this is
from a paper by Hanley in 2010 reviewing
what happened in the history from 2008
and they actually used basically two
tricks and to this day there's no more
tricks but there's two matrix and one is
hashing to take exact sub sequences in
the reeds and check where they match two
and then there is the use of what's
called an FM index and I'll just tell
you a little bit about why what that is
before I tell you more about why people
align so you're not about the
burrows-wheeler transform and the FM
index it's basically an extra decoration
on top of the burrows-wheeler transform
years or it so you have a string
abracadabra and you take you have a
dollar sign to the end and then you
cyclically permute it at all anyways if
it's got any letters in this case 12 and
you put it in matrix your that's short
the rows of this matrix by the first
character dollar comes first and then
you see ya a BBC Drad you guys see that
they're okay and now what you do is you
so this sorting actually turns this into
kind of what's called a suffix array so
you're also heard about and you usually
burrows-wheeler transform you just
ignore all this and you record this
string here actually before I even say
anything else I a personal goal for the
semester is to find some cover notorious
to think about this because in the study
of the doors real chance some people
have actually thought so much about this
is kind of a map it's a sort of a
permutation map and it has very
interesting properties some of which
have conjectured a little bit sub
interesting study but in the LF
transform
you have another sequence your f okay
excuse me and if you look at the point
of the sequence up is to be able to map
the positions l the sequences are now to
the positions in the sequence and
there's actually been a new insight in
string ecology of this stuff to do this
kind of mapping with mismatches so I'm
getting out of time and I want to talk
more about this today but you're very
very interesting apps very interesting
computer science and a lot of progress
actually on milking more out of the
basic bars road transport via this LF
transform which basically IDEs to this
position as out to this string L as I've
said a couple of extra maps so what are
read the language used for yes yeah if
you should explain what's the difference
between what you can get out of ours
Weaver transform and suffix array or so
to speak okay so what you get out of a
person Chuck no I don't want answer your
question in detail but what I will say
is that the point of the birds will
transform is that instead of storing a
matrix which is N squared because you
have n permutations and a sequence of
length n you store sequence of length
and that's the point so whatever you
have either not shall I more than others
yourself yep these single points of
borrows via the Transformers you're
going to pay just to bits because you
have a little elf of it third location
rather than log n bits in it that's it I
mean this has to be really really well
nailed because people don't seem to
understand yeah that's what I said but
that's that's in an action which one it
just which guarantee you that in the
worst case we shall not do string
matching we cannot do three matching
based on a suffix tree or subset you
sorry what's at that point I don't
understand now there are some lower
bounds so whatever combinatorial
technique you may use in the worst case
if you're using
it sucks three like data structure yes
there are lower balance that tell you
that you won't be able to do is in sub X
what I'm sure thing ty is another matter
I said the point here is face of the
yeah that's kind of the point here but
you're right yeah there are bounds on
suffix raised but here the point more
space and it came about specifically
because the human genome is about three
billion base pairs and suffix tree is an
eraser difficult space-wise that's the
basic point I agree so what are we to
read the line that's used for so this is
a picture from the kind of browser of
read alignments so each gray bar here is
a read and they're all stacked upon each
other and they all have sequences in
them which are not shown but here you
can actually see the sequence and you
can see that actually the sequence in
the reference that you align to as a tea
all your reads have a seat so they have
so I said that in real alignment it's
very simple there's a reference there
reads on their errors but I didn't say
where the errors are the errors could be
in the reeds but there's could be in the
reference and I'm using the term error
here kind of loosely because sometimes
it's never the air people slightly abuse
read alignment by comparing that says I
said the genome from one person to the
reference of another not quite that
these sequences came from this one so
that's one thing people do with three
alignments is they try to find
differences like this but another thing
that people try to do with read
alignments and in fact by far has become
the more most widely used most common
thing to do with three the language is
to count and so there's a whole bunch of
new asses where you'd like to measure
something and count it and in order to
do that your sequence okay how do you do
that so the kind of reduction you'd like
to measure something you did some
biochemistry and you make DNA sequence
Stan if you were to sequence them and
count how many of the different types
you got you could not figure a
measurement back so what is the singular
assay of this kind that's most widely
used and therefore has become the
dominant application of DNA sequencing
and read alignment is prenatal testing
so starting about two or three years ago
maybe a bit more people started looking
at the application of the fact that
there's fetal DNA in the plasma of
mothers while they're pregnant and
therefore by sequencing DNA from the
plasma and Counting read alignments to
chromosome 21 specifically you could
figure out whether the fetus has trisomy
21 or down syndrome this is now almost a
standard procedure soon probably I think
it's already many of my friends who are
pregnant I've actually have this
procedure done it's almost soon to
become standard for every single child
more than anywhere in the world that you
would sequence other day because you can
look actually from any kind of
abnormalities and sometimes it's useful
to know that before the birth so this
has become the dominant mode of sequence
alignment in addition to that there are
very deep molecular biology assays that
rely on the same principle there are now
hundreds the first one was published in
2007 it's called chip seek and I won't
say that much about it because I'd like
to leave some time for questions did you
have a question so no so this is an
asset for measuring where protein binds
DNA and the yoga yours to take the
protein and do various things and end up
with DNA sequences that when you align
them and you look where the aligned well
that was a signature for the protein
bound there hopefully another assays RNA
seek which is sequencing of RNA so the
idea here is kind of similar we have a
well my call transcriptome in a cell or
tissue a single seller in the tissue
collection of cells in bulk RNA seek and
you'd like to know how much of each
transcript there are so now the settee
is all transcripts and
you do a bit of magic and you can
convert the RNA into DNA the chicken
sequence and then by lining the DNA to
the targets you can figure out how much
of each one you have so again a very
common essay and as I just said there
are now many many such assays and I'm
looking to go through them for this
particular tutorial but there are
literally dozens of such assets that
measure everything from the then you
know accessibility of chromatin
methylation of DNA binding of Perkins to
DNA binding of RNA to DNA structure of
RNA translation by a ribosome profiling
where the ribosomes are located on the
transcripts just a ton of assays and
they're all about County and so people
are doing read alignments to do all
these things okay so let me just say a
word about sequence counting in
essentially all these assays lets you
try some u21 the question is you have a
read this is chromosome 1 18 21 you just
want to know is this read from
chromosome 21 hours and actually from
some other chromosome or didn't have too
many airs and I can't tell where its fur
that's what you actually care about you
in terms of the original maps I gave you
you don't care about the map sigh you
know L sub sorry elsabeth you care about
sigh you care is this from here is this
from your you're actually care to detect
trisomy 21 I mean you might care it
might be useful but at least the way
they do it now you just carry is this
from here you don't care whether that
specific basis from there from there
okay okay you're going to count how many
copies of this they are relative to the
other chromosomes because increasingly
21 is an extra coffee so that's an
insight and by now well about two years
ago actually my former student Nicholas
by sort of had what I call an elementary
but important insight which is that
is actually what you really care about
is this map saw that's it and you notice
that essentially all read alignment
programs we're producing the maps l sub
F so the point of the bars will
transform I mean well you asked a
different question like what's the point
of that relative to Suffolk surveys but
part of the point of the bars will
transform is to be able to tell for
every single base where it actually
aligns and in fact the bowtie program
which is called bowtie because its bars
wheeler initially actually could not do
alignments where there is an insertion
or deletion because that's difficult to
do with the burrows-wheeler transform
and for a number of years when you're
aligning reads if there was an error of
an insertion or deletion it just
wouldn't align and they fixed that in
bowtie too but it took to I think more
than two years maybe 2,000 yeah took a
long time I I don't know why but I'll
give some practical advice people still
use boat i won a lot without indels by
not a good idea so so one point is that
you pay a big cost with the
burrows-wheeler transform it's very very
difficult to massage it to be able to do
these other things so you have this idea
that may be sued alignment could be
computed much much faster than
alignments and maybe that's all we care
about he called the pseudo lemon and as
I said in terms of this kind of picture
you just said like let's throw away that
information then it turns out it's
actually kind of an interesting question
to ask how do you sudo line very quickly
all right so I mean in a sense people
and no kind of how to see the line very
quickly for a long time because you know
if you build a hash you can exactly
match a sequence somewhere you know
essentially you have a dictionary you
can look up sequences in their exact
matches the gas is something sort of
different because you know that is
asking for a lot sure you can suit
online by you're asking for every base
here to be exactly
in one of your targets figure out which
target next let's relax that assumption
and just ask can we tell where this
aligns allowing for errors but not
worrying about individual base pair
alignment and we actually searched a lot
and we couldn't find anybody that dumps
even though it's a very obvious question
so we thought about it a bit and one of
our colleagues pardon else that is
computer science professor University of
Iceland we had a nice idea of how to
organize this and I'll tell you a bit
about the algorithm because I actually
came to believe and I really believe
this now that we don't actually care to
study the burrows-wheeler transform
anymore or the FM index or suffix arrays
for this application because I don't
think you actually want to align reads
basically ever okay so I've become
convinced of this that you should never
all language so I didn't want to teach
you how to do it I want to teach how to
do this all right so what's the idea so
probably the idea that you both the
brain graph from the targets that you're
trying to line two and here I've given
the example of transcripts so these are
transcript sequences so green continues
here with the gap blue continues there
but this could be any targets and it is
that you'd like to build a de brain
graph from them now I know many of the
folks in this audience know a lot about
the brain graph because they used an
assembly this is not the kind of this
has nothing to do with assembly that
you're not assembling reads here but
you're building a kind of data structure
that is used an assembly to the same
exact data structure it's just a
different repurposing of the same data
structure what your day or is you take
gamers from these sequences so short
sequences of length K and you declare
two cameras to be adjacent in the graph
if they overlap at all but they're
single ends single n bass players so the
camera is tile this graph the graph and
the actual targets are kind of path so
on this graph so they overlay this graph
so green is there but you see beers and
then pink have an extra piece so they
you know they go over like that so you
build this data structure very simple
data structure
you can build this the instructure very
efficiently it's very easy because you
just extract the cameras and you know
sequentially just glue them onto each
other so we've actually found in
practice for the kinds of read
alignments we do that you'd use like the
31 mer that's because reads nowadays
kind of start at fifty seventy five
hundred and fifty sometimes 250 you know
if the old days reads were 30 base pairs
you would use a smaller k but we use k
plus 31 we also choose K to be odd
because it turns out to build these when
you build these graphs and I've glossed
over this detail today you know
sequences in DNA come in the Ford and in
the reverse complement and you actually
identify the cameras and the reverse
compliments in this data structure it's
more convenient that way and when you do
that you can do even k but it gets
complicated and the reason it's a good
exercise to figure out why it's
complicated I'm not going to tell you
can think about what it is about reverse
compliments and odd sequences that go
well together so we create this thing we
call it a trench target the brain graph
that's kind of what it stands for you
can index very quickly on a big genome
and in very little memory so all that
stuff about burrows-wheeler transform
you don't have to worry about now if you
have a read that's Anakin's exactly from
one of these targets of gianna here
comes from pink so that's this piece of
sequence glued to that one and it has no
errors in an ideal world then your
cameras are consecutive in this graph
right that's just a fact actually let me
say what about if they have errors
there's two cases if you have an error
in one of these cameras actually most
likely it's not in the graph for it to
be in the graph well you'd have to have
a camera you have to have a sequence
somewhere else and you're our target
sequences that's exactly the same but
off by just a tiny but that happens
there duplications and all these targets
but not that common usually when you
have an error you just want find your
camera
alright so you know and this is the
whole idea we actually got a paper out
of this kind of ridiculous because it's
so simple but sometimes just you did
something I nobody thought about before
is you look up each of your cameras in
your read and you do that with the hash
so that's very fast so you look up
camera and you know it goes there camera
goes there chemicals their chemicals
their grandma's good and you just look
up you've stored for each of these
cameras in this graph you just stored
the colors so you know this one it comes
from green pink and blue and so on and
you just intersect these colors and by
taking that intersection you now find
out that this specific read actually
have to come from blue pink could not
have come from green okay so that's
basically an algorithm not necessarily
the element but an algorithm for doing
quick suit alignment now we're in our
paper they wrong about this we do a lot
of tricks for example here's an idea
when you look up this camer in this data
structure you can simply record how far
away that notice from that node and if
you know that there's no splits in
between this note and not node then
there's no point to look up this camera
as well you might as well just go to the
intersection you're not going to learn
anything new because all the colors are
the same and actually we've now shown
that for just using this kind of
trickery foremost reads you can sue the
line them by looking at two cameras
actually even one single camera but then
you're alive some scenarios so that
means that you can take an entire read
and just glance at it and figure out
where they should go so we wrote a
program we wrote a program to do this
it's called Callisto and it performs
this pseudo lineman it makes reader line
retractable on the laptop it's really
fast there's a really interesting
algorithmic question maybe for the
semester we haven't thought about this
too much but it is an interesting
question this is not we looked at really
is sort of with respect to suit
alignment I should have written sue the
lemon here like what or kind of lower
bounds an upper bound you know
lower bounds lets say by aqua bands I
mean actual algorithms that can do this
kind of thing with respect to specific
air models and specific models of the
sequence that you assume so you know
let's say assuming sequences Markovian
you have a certain kind of error rate
then what's the actual optimally to do
actual pseudo alignment so now you allow
yourself to you know you don't care to
align the basis just you want to get the
target right and can you get the target
rights and large percentage of the time
so I don't know if they're integral work
in this direction that would be
interested the goal is to basically be
able to do this much faster that your
sub sub linearly our current
implementation of this the whole thing
runs in about four times maybe five
times word count so as to say if you
take your reads and just count the
characters is about five times as long
so but you'd like to be going much lower
than that and hopefully then big eight
then all these large numbers of reads
done well under an issue for you all
right let me let me just conclude with
one last piece I know everybody's a bit
tired and what a half hours a long time
there's a kind of final problem that
goes along with read alignment that I
haven't discussed but that's crucial to
it and that is that the reeds actually
can you believe they can from the
targets that's the model here there's no
evolutionary relationships but yo you at
the end of the HR to count how many read
jack from each target so in a nice
universe that's all good and you can
write out the likelihood for seeing you
know this many reads from green red and
blue and do your statistics for your for
your measurement that you're trying to
do by coming actually if you want to
testament the proportionably you just
take the number of counts here divided
by the total it's not rocket science but
in practice in reader language there's a
key issue which I've not addressed which
is that the alignments are going to come
up as ambiguous this happened in my
previous cartoon where that little read
was the biggest two pink or blue most
reads come up and vigorously because
genomes are highly duplicated
and because reads to this day are kind
of short now one thing uh I think I had
a point about this towards the end but
people often ask me why I work on this
problem because you know guys are hard
at work people hard at work trying to
like get long long reads you hear about
in the news all the time so I'll be out
of business soon because once the reads
are long it's all kind of a trivial
problem actually eventually there's just
one read yeah starting to begin with
molecule read to the end of the molecule
is like what's there to do I don't have
time today but in many of these assays
you will not you will never get long
reads because the nature of the counting
is such the nature preparing the DNA
that you just it doesn't make sense to
get longer it's biologically you can't
get so that's a key point to keep in
mind and because of that the reads are
often ambiguous and so what do people do
about that so there's all sorts of
ambiguity that happens and your data is
really not the counts of red green and
blue but this whole mixture of colors
and so what people do is they write out
like lead function where you take the
product over all the subsets of colors
and then you sum up the probability for
each of the different categories and
these alphas are the probability you
came from red or green or blue and you
take it to the power of the number of
reads you sell from that category and
these categories be subsets they have a
name now called equivalence classes and
these kind of shoot alignments what they
actually produce our Koons class counts
so they're very perfectly suited for
this kind of statistical framework and
what people do with this kind of
framework is there on the EML rhythms
some similar in numerical optimization
so other many other choices to try to
maximize for these parameters doing so
is a key part of rita language some
this is called read assignment and it's
an interesting problem in to turn right
it requires a model and if i wanted to
mention it in the tutorial the basically
an algorithm is easy to understand you
start out assuming that your targets
have equal frequency what you'd kind of
like to do with these ambiguously
mapping sequences is give them a
probability from being from blue or
green and so on if you near the actual
abundances well you could declare the
probability off the bat you know if this
if red is twice as a button is blue and
you see read that's and biggest between
the two well it's twice as likely a come
from right but you don't know that so
you start off guessing that they're
equal abundance and then you take each
of your reads and you're just proportion
apportion it according to these
abundances so you know see for example
and biggest between blue and red you
give a half the count to Blair half
account to read and then yep you add up
those fractional counts and you
normalize everything to sum to 1 and you
get a new pie chart and then you split
the reeds according to the new pie chart
this is called the em algorithm and it
has been discovered many times just like
hierarchies and laminar families and
this is an algorithm is kind of I think
it's a good intuition for what read
assignment is doing there may be
different ways to do read assignment and
many different algorithms for it so I'll
end with that I want you to leave a
couple of minutes for questions so to
conclude a few final thoughts I've just
said this that breed 11 is a technology
problem but it will persist because
there are many applications where the
reeds inherently need to be short and
this is a highly parallel way to make
measurements by Counting it's a good
good a say this is a very in my mind an
interesting direction to explore there's
been all this work now on fast methods
for read alignment and maybe there are
some tech transfer to go back to to
sequence alignment and actually apply
some of these ideas I've had a couple of
conversations with the folks used to do
sequence alignment they all jump
many of them work on Rita like me now
but sequence alignments extremely
important problem and now it's a better
time than any to work on it because we
have huge numbers of genomes now and no
real knowledge of the algorithms and the
statistics and all the idea is necessary
to align them so highly on completely
uncomfortable i'm at wikipedia page so
that my next talk is easy to prepare
thank you very much yep wonder how far
you can take this idea of pseudo
alignment instead of alignments because
a person with many of the whatever
favorite see cast is like chip seek you
would want to know where it comes from
so you for gene expression of course
when you talk about alternative splicing
that's already sort of a gray zone right
so you could think of excellent i'm
being its own target essentially but
often there you already care how many
research is finding the exon junction
and so for that you already need to know
some positional information and not just
the assignments so how far do you think
that paradigm takes you yeah so I mean
there are definitely applications for
example give you one I think is even
more in the direction you're asking
about for example you know people
interested to use by na seek and the
sequencer cannot to find edits to do
read editing so that is to find specific
differences between the reeds and the
actual targets and sure you know that's
that's the kind of important thing to do
but I actually believe that pseudo imma
can solve those problems as well because
the thing is that you know it would be
interesting to write down a whole list
of everything we have kind of started in
our minds we have lots of ideas but
let's say something like Reid is editing
you don't actually care to align the
vast majority of the reads what you
actually care to do is to align the
reeds which actually have a difference
with the actual targets and if you think
about that in the course of doing suit
alignment it can actually be pretty easy
to identify those reeds possibly you
know you know so
so sudo lima can actually allow you to a
line actually read a line subsets of
your reads possibly much much faster
than you would if you just the Langille
and so I would argue that even for read
editing even though the ultimate goal
are read alignments for very specific
reads it's only for a very small subset
and I kind of feel that this is true for
most of the cases where you would think
of actual specific alignments and you
know once we we've heard from a lot of
biologists there I mean I didn't say
this but you can actually kind of you
know there isn't a complete how shall I
say you read a lineman read student
alignment are not just completely
separate there's a spectrum in between I
didn't talk about it but there's ideas
that people call lightweight alignment
or read mapping sometimes although read
mapping usually means read alignment but
let's say a lightweight alignment where
you in the light you know you you can
maybe extract not detail the lining for
every base but you can maybe know the
first base when it actually lines to and
it turns out to be actually very easy to
do that for example in the debris in
graph I won't pop it up again you can
actually store for each of those nodes
where it is in the genome and so you
just when you look up your first camera
you just ask where is it not to get into
till alignment it's complicated because
you're going to have errors in the
middle and you know what goes where but
very fast extract the beginning of the
read so I think those ideas will solve
all this is your rest of the steady
stuff and the hills okay so basically
the way its handling errors is that when
you have an error your your your your
camer does is almost certainly not align
so that's good you just ignored I mean
you don't care to have every camer it's
just not a path in the graph now
occasionally you do have a camera that
actually is in the graph somewhere else
and then you get basically an
interesting when you take the whole
intersection you get the empty set and
then there's a number of interesting
things you can do you can
say okay let me go back and try to
figure this out more carefully and we
can do that so or you can actually flag
cases like this and put them in a bucket
because it turns out we've been looking
at them a lot they're very interesting
because there's usually there's biology
that underlines direction case so that's
in a nutshell yeah can you go back to
this little I'm in the figure yes this
one or the next one the one that shows
on this one so with the exception of
shrinking the SE non bifurcating boss
it's why do you need the graphical
because why are you actually storing the
actual edges in the graph you're asking
um yeah you don't really need to store
the edges it's true no you don't we
actually so when we first built this we
built do you know we didn't know how
well it would work how fast it would be
we probably build this is kind of a
research tool and we have explored
removing and adding all sorts of
information in and out of this graph but
yeah you're right you don't actually
care to know that this you know it's
nice to know how far this cameras from
the intersection and so in principle if
you know that for every camera you can
work back which are Jason but yeah
absolutely true
when you get the week about a sign yeah
so you can take those reeds and do
detailed alignment although as I said to
you know I think for most applications
you just want to know where those reach
start you know I don't really see many
applications where you truly need to
take every read and do it to tell the
lineman for I just think that's never
going to be necessary I me biologists
are used to seeing those alignments in
pictures on screens so they feel
comfortable with them but once you move
away from that and just trust the
algorithm I don't see why you would care
it has no practical application for what
you're actually working with if you
don't know that we're working on so this
is a very very good point but if you do
not know your chance if you do not know
your transcriptome you don't do read a
link so then you do read assembly right
and yeah that's hi honey yes and we know
they're in our genomic region we don't
know how the splicing is going with
pseudo alignment to that region help
with so very good question I've thought
a bit about pioneers there they're the
hardest thing to work on my suggestion
for those would be work on something
else next 200 no I'm kidding no I'm
kidding yeah very good question i mean
say you're asking a really good question
where and I should give an honest answer
to it Greg which is that I give a
slightly dishonest answer it's not the
case usually they either don't know your
chance to your targets in your
transcript or more you know it perfectly
well the reality is that's an even in
the human or mouse which are the most
effort has been put into them you know
the transcriptome kind of right you're
missing stuff and what the point of the
pseudo alignment is is that you can take
the vast majority of your reads an
Alanis I online them or assign them even
leaving yourself a very small bucket
with which to actually do the alignments
and work with as i was telling of it and
i think that's the right way to go about
things because then you can spend a lot
of time and do really like
assembly in and we've actually you know
I've done that so we have not
publishable work yet but we have all
sorts of experiments probably why we're
building these graphs you know we we
play with assemblers in our group and we
take do things like take the reads that
don't align assemble them see what comes
out so you know yeah that's exactly what
we're doing and I think that can totally
help with looks like these pioneers oh
yeah alright thanks again thanks let's
go